Mamamia here we go again brings to life
Donna and the dynamos back story and
gloriously fun fashion but hidden in
that prequel story and many
inconsistencies that contradict plot
points and details from the original
movie yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's
Jan here and today I'm going to reveal
and explain five ways that Mamma Mia two
completely ignored what happened in the
first film obviously some spoilers ahead
if you haven't seen the movie apparently
resurrection is a thing in the Mamma Mia
universe because in the original movie
it's heavily implied that Donna's mother
is already dead
somebody up there has got it in for me I
bet it's my mother Helen wasn't sharing
up son however in the sequel Donna's
mother ruby is still very much alive and
kicking and makes a late but
show-stopping entrance in the form of
Cher who reunites with her lost love
Cienfuegos while belting out Fernando at
the end of the day Ruby's revival for
Mamma Mia - is basically down to
writer-director old Parker who wrote the
part specifically for Cher and saw the
chance to make the sequel deeper moodier
by digging into the strained
mother/daughter relationship briefly
mentioned in the first film as if
raising the dead wasn't enough cher is
actually only three years older in real
life than Meryl Streep who plays her
on-screen daughter still Al Parker says
that cher exists separate from time and
we should just enjoy the show and not
worry our heads about such things and I
have to say I agree with him as frankly
who doesn't want to see cher lend her
inimitable style to ABBA classics while
dressed in sparkly tops white suits and
flowered Flair's in the first movie
Colin first Harry tells Sophie that when
he was young he bought a guitar for
Donna and it cost him 10 pounds and his
Johnny Rotten t-shirt now in the sequel
young Harry was a Johnny Rotten t-shirt
during his Parisian adventures with
young Donna but after he's bought the
guitar he's still wearing that same
t-shirt also how did he ever actually
give young Donna that guitar because in
the sequel although heusken as Harry
does follow Donna to grease he misses
the ferry to the island and the last
time we see him he's walking away from
the dark lamenting his fate
maybe in this new version of the story
young Harry decided to leave the guitar
for Donna with someone on the island
like imagine Lily's Greek official or
perhaps there's a cutscene that explains
how it ended up with her indeed there
does appear to be
missing part of the original Mamma Mia
timeline in the sequel because in the
first film
Donna's diary says that Harry turned up
out of the blue so she said she'd show
him the islands speaking of Donna's
diary in the first movie it said she met
and slept with Sam first on July the
17th followed by Bill on August the 4th
and finally Harry on August the 11th
however that's not quite the way things
happen in the sequel and here we go
again
Donna first meets and sleeps with a
young Harry in Paris then she meets but
doesn't sleep with a young Bill in
Greece after which she meets and falls
in love with a young Sam and finally she
meets up with Bill again and this time
sleeps with him when Lily James was cast
in the lead she says she was so clear
that Donna's sex life had to be
celebrated but admits that at first she
was worried the producers would try and
dampen it down so she was very glad when
they embraced it for writer-director old
Parker although Donna's three
relationships are relatively short it
was important to make each one
meaningful and I think that's the key to
why he changed the order of events from
Donna's original diary the idea being
that Harry was a charming vacation fling
then she fell in love with Sam but he
was already engaged and left her at
which point bill was there to help her
over her broken heart another miraculous
thing about the momomiya universe is how
people's eye colors seemed to completely
change over the years so Alexa Davies
young Rosie has blue eyes compared to
Julie Walters brown eyes Hugh Skinner's
eyes as young Harry a much lighter than
column first brown eyes and while Meryl
Streep's Donna has blue eyes Lily James
has brown eyes although the filmmakers
wanted the younger characters to really
remind audiences of their older
counterparts they were never looking for
a mirror image when here we go again was
casting Lily James was actually busy on
a publicity tour for baby driver but
director ol park insisted the Mamamia
team wait until she had time to meet
with them that's because as the
filmmakers have said Lily transcends
whether you think she looks exactly like
Meryl she's a tour de force and a
natural storyteller in her singing for
her part James has said she tried to
pick a few characteristics or
expressions or a physicality that would
make us hopefully believe her version of
Donna would grow into Meryl Streep's and
Streep herself was given James her seal
of approval saying she really did
capture
young Donna's spirit it's perhaps a
little odd that James or the other axis
didn't work colored contacts to change
their eye color for the film so I wonder
if maybe one of them couldn't wear them
for some reason or maybe the filmmakers
thought it just wasn't a big deal either
way their different eye colors totally
pale into insignificance when you
consider their great performances
especially Lily James and the way she
brings to life a young Donna and let's
not forget what Donna's three love
interests look like when they first met
her in the original movie compared to
how they look in the sequel goner yung
Sam's long locks headband large mustache
and hippie clothes and young villas also
had a bit of a haircut and a change of
wardrobe from his more flowerpower style
to young Harry still has a leather
jacket but Ghana has studded leather
choker and eyeliner and his hair styles
also less punky of course as Colin Firth
Pierce Brosnan and stellan skarsgård
very briefly played younger versions of
themselves in the original movie the
costume and makeup Department had a bit
of fun with how they made those actors
look different from their present-day
selves at the time however the
filmmakers obviously didn't want to
extend that few seconds long joke from
the original film into a very lengthy
joke in the sequel and so when it came
to clothes and hairstyles they went for
less exaggerated looks that would appeal
more generally to modern audiences by
the way homage Elena's Greek official
really did seem very interested in
people's changing hairstyles perhaps a
bit of meta-commentary and a wink to
fans of the franchise of course when
they made the original Mamma Mia as they
didn't intend to make a sequel so their
creative decisions then didn't take into
account what they might want to do in a
second movie ten years later they didn't
want to be constrained too much by
choices made or throwaway lines in the
first film for me the differences are
interesting as they give us some insight
into the filmmakers thought processes
and I still really love both the movies
they're made to be fun enjoyable and
entertaining and they are so did any of
these changes bother you and did you
spot any other differences between the
two movies let me know in the comments
below for a chance to win one of these
awesome Mamma Mia too much pax make sure
you subscribe leave me a comment about
the film and also tap the gleam link in
the video description below to register
your entry I'll have a brand new member
me a video for you shortly so tap left
to watch the next one or tap right for
my full Mamma Mia
musicals playlist if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a thumbs up thanks for
watching and see you next time you PKA
movie lovers